it's truly wonderful to see a completely
full auditorium and it's not just a full
audience it's a diverse audience we have
people registered to be here from at
least 63 different nations so this is a
really global meeting
I'm gonna talk about the future of
intelligence the word itself goes back
to a Latin word which means understand I
really loved that the discussion was not
just about the future of technology and
artificial intelligence but but more
about the human implications for that I
don't think of myself as a critic I not
anti-technology I'm Pro conversation
there's a lot of discussion now about
both the possibilities and the threats
of artificial intelligence so the timing
while this discussion was absolutely
right I have been through meetings where
technically they're open to the public
but the public don't come they hear they
do I was really excited about coming
here I wanted to dialogue this is my
first time so getting the chance to get
to know the
here is very inspired one of the most
amazing things is actually the
conversations you have during the coffee
breaks with the people here where you
get to get under their skin and find out
about what they're really thinking about
it's wonderful my head they're still
spinning
another week dialog is challenging we
have discussions them about very
important topics I think it's a unique
experience I think it's quite impressive
to be able to listen to a Nobel laureate
you read about them in a newspaper you
might see them in Time magazine or
whatever but actually listen to them
talk is quite compelling I just think
it's superb you well done event did you
get to see people that you don't see
every day in your life and there are
like policy makers and there are Lords
who are very intelligent and you can see
things and hear things from different
angle than what you would have expected
or would have thought by yourself bring
these people together to share their
minds and their thoughts and that's
where the dialogue is about this is
Nobel Week dialogue
you